blizzard designer Jeff Kaplan has opened
up about working on tighten the
cancelled mm oh that was positioned as
the studio successor to World of
Warcraft I'm Lucy and welcome to your
games what news updates Titan was
officially announced in December 2010
but remained shrouded in secrecy before
ultimately being cancelled in September
2014 speaking in an interview with
GameSpot captain said that Titans
development team failed terrifically an
experience that was unfamiliar to
developers that had previously helped
craft some of blizzards biggest titles
he said you had a really amazing group
that was working on Titan they were
really talented individuals but we
failed horrific ly in every way in every
way that a project can fail it was
devastating you had these people who
either came from other companies or from
within blizzards and were used to
working on games that were very
successful like a world of warcraft for
example to go through such a complete
and utter failure is very hard for
people who are used to experiencing
success in the silence after titans
collapse the team found itself feeling
the pressure of making up for its
failure particularly as strong new
projects joined blizzards staple of
successes nobody said a word everyone
was super supportive but I think there
was this inward embarrassment of like no
we need to prove that we're worthy of
being at Blizzard 2 we can make
something that makes the company proud
it was a trying period of time and there
was a lot of pressure the team is used
to pressure but never quite at that
magnitude and it helped to forge us in a
lot of ways in the fallout Titans
development team found itself doing some
soul-searching and eventually that
shared experience of failure gave rise
to a stronger drive to rebound with
something new it was kind of a crisis of
confidence and by density where you
start to ask yourself did we lose it do
we not know who we are anymore are we
not capable of making a great game
anymore I think a lot of us were asking
ourselves on an individual basis that
question so when it came to move to
overwatch there was an extremely tight
bond on the team and a ravenous hunger
to show the world that we're not
failures and we can make something
really fun well at least an aside for
yourself when overwatch officially
launches for PC Xbox one and ps4 on May
24 for more on overwatch
keep your eyes peeled to gamespot we're
publishing a series of in-depth videos
hosted by Danny O'Dwyer delving into the
creation of the first new Blizzard IP
for 17 years